today's Cloud tip is for anyone looking
to learn more about artificial
intelligence for those newer to AI
knowing where to start learning can feel
intimidating but luckily Google cloud
has some great resources for this one of
my favorites is our Ai and machine
learning playlist it has over 150 videos
from our channel that cover everything
from getting started videos intros to
sdks and demos showing you how to add AI
solutions to your own applications so if
you're ready to start your Learning
Journey with AI check out the link in
our description to see our full playlist
and make sure to subscribe to our
channel for more learning resources